big news kind of or not really depending
on who you talk to the Justice
Department has announced they're no
longer going to use or contract with
private prisons period they did an
investigation which turned up the exact
same thing that every other
investigation into the matter has turned
up which is that private prisons by and
large are less safe then government run
prisons they're less effective at
providing correctional services which is
almost funny to read who thinks prisons
are in the business of providing
correctional or rehabilitative services
at this point right yeah uh and that it
basically just doesn't make sense to
contract with private prisons so that's
good news I like that the problem is
this doesn't apply to that many people
because this decision number one affects
only federal contracts with private
prisons most prison inmates nationally
are not in federal prisons they're in
state prisons and this decision by the
Justice Department is absolutely nothing
to impact the fact that state
governments are still using private
prisons and the other thing is we've
talked about this many times and I'm I
don't know Jason if you're aware of this
but people often like to talk about the
the huge importance of eliminating
private prisons I agree incarceration
should not be for profit but only about
eight or nine percent of of inmates
nationally are in private prisons and
that's one of those things were as
progressives we want to inform and the
right position is to be against private
prisons but let's also not overstate how
many people are even in private prisons
I don't know if it's shocking to you
that only eight or nine percent of
inmates are in private prisons but ten
percent of the world largest prison
population that's still probably
sniffing number like even compared to
worldwide that's probably still more
prisoners and many people even have in
raw numbers there is no doubt that the
private prison population of the u.s.
rivals the total prison population of
many countries no doubt about it but
let's let's remember exactly what the
scope of this is so uh and lastly we've
talked a little bit Louis about how
immigrations enforcement has these deals
with private prisons where they will
hold people pending deportation or
pending hearings in private prisons and
it's a really big moneymaker
the private prisons this federal
decision does not impact immigrations
related detention in private prisons so
yes it's a victory in that it is the
right decision it's a victory in that it
might start getting us in the right
direction but it really is impacting a
tiny portion of inmates nationally yes
still a good thing though because these
these prisons are terrible and maybe
this will eventually lead to some type
of federal mandate against private
prisons i'm sure the thought of a
private prison too many people listening
in other countries yeah i just doesn't
even make sense no doubt about it uh
libertarians are sort of split on this
this is one of those issues were
libertarians will sometimes split and
some will go off to the kooky recesses
of the internet some libertarians are
sort of against the concept of prison
some of them actually say we should go
back to when you commit a crime and you
as the perpetrator are required to
compensate the victim which basically
means if you have a lot of money and you
figure out what the price is for a rape
you can say hey I can afford ten rapes a
year i'll just pay people often that's
that that is one libertarian view others
are sort of against the prison
industrial complex not because they're
opposed to making incarceration for
profit per se if the market will bear it
as they like to say but because they
just think the entire system of how
people are brought to justice the police
system the legal system it's all totally
illegitimate those people I also don't
agree with and then you have the more
reasonable libertarians who say you know
what if we are going to take away
someone's liberty by imprisoning them
and that is such a serious
responsibility and big thing for the
government you should never attach a
profit motive that is a libertarian s
belief that I can actually get behind
that makes perfect sense yeah um and if
if it's justice and that's a that's what
we do yeah right let's not have it be
for profits and uh please read about the
conditions some of these profit
for-profit prisons yeah any thoughts on
that Jason you seemed like you were
anxious to get in there I was gonna say
you know it seems like I'm not sure this
in education but it seems like you know
should be the same for for many of these
things you know education be non profit
as well really I've been reading a lot
of the comments online and many people
reacting to this
by saying great now let's move on to
health care and education to other
institutions that should not be made uh
for profit that's something we've talked
about pretty often gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30 day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s